why can't we just have the Star Trek
Legacy that we want why do we have to
have Star Trek 90210 instead welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
if you are a Trekkie and you're on
Twitter or Facebook groups and so on and
so on you will probably know that the
fans have been talking about Star Trek
Legacy now for months we want a Terry
metallist-led Star Trek series that
follows on the adventures of the Titan a
maybe sure is still the captain maybe he
dies in the next two episodes every
episode he survives I'm just in shock I
think they basically keep trying to kill
him and he just goes no and and they
can't but anyway and then seven of nine
maybe she's Captain I don't know we'd
like to see some of the young actors
come through maybe the kids of some of
the TNG crew maybe some of the TNG crew
themselves returning Marina certis and
Gates McFadden have already hinted that
if the fans want it that maybe this
isn't the final Voyages of the Next
Generation
but it seems that we're not going to be
getting Legacy that there's very little
interest in Legacy now I've actually
told you that through sources I've got
that work in and around this industry
that actually there has been some
interest expressed by Paramount
Executives about Terry matalis I told
you there's a marketing meeting about a
month ago the person I speak to doesn't
actually work for Paramount but the
company they do work for was doing quite
a big project for Paramount and they
were presenting this Project's results
during that conversation they were asked
about Picard season three now that
wasn't part of their original project
but they gave their opinion
pecan season 3 is apparently pleasantly
surprised some people at Paramount
they've been very pleasantly surprised
by the trekkies response
us the old enough to remember the
Millennium trekkies and even though it
is true that before Picard season 3
there was no interest really in pushing
forwards with that new Terror metallis
Star Trek show that about halfway
through Picard season three when the
numbers really began to Skyrocket and
Picard season 3 found a much wider
audience suddenly the interest in Abu
terramatale show grew but apparently
they're hitting a brick wall and that
brick wall is called Alex kurtzman
Alex kurzman really wants to do
Starfleet Academy this is a show that's
been going around for years decades even
and he really really wants to push on
with the discovery storyline and this is
the way he can do that Discovery was
kurtzman's baby he doesn't want it to
die he wants it to push forwards
he also desperately wants to do section
31 I mean from what I'm hearing he's
desperate to do section 31. he is
desperate for Michelle yotropy and he
wants to direct that series but why is
he so desperate
because Alex kurtzman according to a
couple of rumors I've heard and I'm
saying these are rumors has Ambitions
Beyond Star Trek and directing
oscar-winning Michelle yeoh will not
hurt those Ambitions at all
he is desperate to do this because he
wants that on his CV and he is blocking
any suggestion of Stargate Legacy
because it would interfere with his
long-term plan
now
I've also heard some rumors that is
actually insanely jealous of the success
of Picard season 3 that obviously he has
had very little to do with this season
he had a lot to do with seasons one or
two he had a lot to do with discovering
he's not had much to do with strange new
worlds and that's been very popular
apparently he's not very happy about
that either he's been very quiet about
Picard season three when he has been
pinned out by reporters he's talked
about section 31 an academy he's not
talked about the success of Picard
that's is unusual now I really hope
these rumors are not true because if
they are that makes Alex kurtzman an
incredibly selfish and Petty person
and I really would like to think that a
professional in his sort of position
would be more than that but he would
look at what time metallis has done a
show that he is still executive producer
and by the way Alex gertram is still
attached to this and he would be happy
for his colleague and he would go you
know what maybe what we did with the
discovery wasn't right wasn't the right
direction maybe we made some mistakes
let's work with Terry let's see what the
fans actually want because then today
let's remember the Star Trek is
entertainment if we want something bad
enough shouldn't we get it that's how we
got strange new worlds according to
people like Anson Mount we got it
because the fans went crazy and
basically demanded it it was not on the
cards at the end of Discovery season two
it was supposed to be a one-off but then
we got the Strange New World's green
light because we loved it so much
shouldn't we get the same Legacy
shouldn't actually Paramount just say
look kurtzman love your section 31 ideas
they're great whether they're doing it
but you know come on the fans want
something set in the 23rd Century they
want this contemporary for us Series in
this time frame we don't want the second
post burn
nonsense anymore we want something with
a bit more joy we want something with a
bit more positivity we don't necessarily
want the big high drama anymore we want
Star Trek
and shouldn't in that case Alex
kurtzmann listen or Paramount should go
elsewhere because at the end of the day
they own the IP
now I know that there are going to be
contracts apparently telling metallic is
on a non-compete so he actually wouldn't
be able to go and work for somebody else
doing Star Trek for a certain period of
time
but surely the conversation with secret
hideout can be done and surely something
can be figured out so that the fans
actually get what they want for me if
even half of the rumors I hear about
Alex Goodson is true
and I'm not saying they are but if they
are
then he really needs to get out of his
own way because he's actually harming a
franchise that has been very good to him
up till now and if he really does have
Ambitions Beyond Star Trek then he needs
to start seriously thinking about the
Legacy that he is leaving because if he
wants to be remembered as the man that
destroyed Star Trek is kind of going the
right way about it
but if he wants to be the man that
actually gave birth to a new track
something that we can all really love
then maybe he needs to get out of his
own way
I'd love you guys again for the comments
don't tell me exactly what you think
about this do you think these rumors
could be true we hear about Petty
selfish self-absorbed people in
Hollywood all the time is it possible
that Alex Goodman's just one of those
people and actually he is willing to cut
his nose off to spite his face
or do you hope like me it is actually a
professional and that hey he might have
Ambitions to direct oscar-winning
Michelle yo but if it doesn't happen
hopefully he will switch Tack and look
at another project and maybe Star Trek
Legacy we'll get a second go
came to the concert tell me exactly what
you're thinking if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack wherever small
contribution each month you can support
the channel and get to see most of our
videos first and without the adverts as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]